welcome to this video round seven in
County man disc the candidates
tournament and this is the game Kramnik
against mamedyarov yeah and certainly a
game of different characters and
different stories of this tournament
Kramnik has just lost the wrong before
gets his big rival to pull off in a very
very drastic fashion am a giraffe has
been yeah in a way gifted a win by
swidler so they are both on fifty
percent are very yeah very defining game
let's say if it will have a winner this
person is really much in contention but
would be especially great for media off
after he started with the minus two and
was basically out of it already and
chronic of course tournament favorite he
also would love to get a win and so that
seemed so we have Queens gambit and it's
the Dorados in which seems my medeiros
main num opening here in county he had
played this before against Aronian in
brought to where he's so awfully give
away the Queen just a couple of moves
later I don't move 1415 somewhere around
that but we get a different line now
Cromley exchanges and plays Bishop g5 97
and Quincy to this is the absolute main
line of the opening Aronian had played
this interesting move okay Quincy to c5
and III this is the most fighting choice
Kramnik is not inform a slow technical
maneuvering game on here he also could
have taken on c5 which very often leads
to earn such a game with them with them
yeah with long maneuvering and games
playing against
slate upon but III the main Queen a 5 53
c for Bishop f5 all this has been played
numerous times I won't do so much about
the opening for this video because
simply the later stage of the game pin
is so complicated I'll never get in this
video below one hour if I do a big
opening serving um cancelled castles
rupee eight yeah the general idea or the
general conflict in this line is between
the center and the Queen side what has
an additional pawn in the center and
active pieces all get towards the center
those bishops knives and so on and black
has a counter play idea on the queenside
you will often capture here and initiate
play with be five a five or sometimes
the night will also join the queenside
play so this is a very sharp line
actually it's um okay very sharp it
depends the night off poison born is
sharper but considering that we were in
a queen's gambit is one of the more
confrontational lines where both sides
actually can hope to to get a full point
simply because of the very much
different approaches to the position of
both sides yeah 92 was played um very
well known move it gives additional
attention to the e4 square and longtime
might prepare play in the center g6 and
now kramnik took on d 7 this is
relatively yeah recent discern may be
the wrong word but the traditional
moopheus bishan to h3 just dropping it
back after which black has the number of
possibilities um one line is king g7 and
this has been played for example in the
game between peter svidler playing white
and chronic playing black in 2010 and
this
melody amber tournament I guess it was a
rapid or blindfold game that so kramnik
is also able to play this as black
couldn't they both have experience with
that okay but here Bishop d7 was played
and this is a move that is get more
towards immediate concrete play as
Bishop a serious more of a strategical
move here after this chronic is a plane
h4 really a aggressive way to play this
has more than one idea it at some point
might prepare h5 but this is not the
midpoint the main thing is this Bishop
is protected now and this allows for
various ideas very often along the
fifth-ranked this Bishop can be a
liability and this is not the case now
it is protected and yeah what is like
supposed to play now Mammadyarov
surprisingly um took a bit of time and
played b 5 which is i mean surprisingly
because this is an absolute main line of
the opening h4 is not the only mujra but
certainly something that he shoot some
preparation against simply because he he
had it on the board already against chip
arena in 2007 I found the game where
madera was black and it was funny enough
played in cantonment ziskin one of the
World Cup events and in that game he
played in I had played Knight b6
Normandy arif very complicated stuff he
lost at the end but it's not necessarily
due to the opening um yeah here played
b5 and after a long long thing okay
chrome Nick responded with a four very
logical move but it is a novelty b5 has
been played once before at least in my
database and in this game the white
player just played a three instead of a
four
a four is just much more logical I guess
it now basically forces blacks reaction
black cannot play a six of course very
very clear he must take the only move
and now we must play before really i
don't see i have anything else otherwise
we get yeah the structure will simply be
terrible what what else should black
play and move like yeah move the Queen
back this will be one day I must do that
this is pretty much more yeah in term to
be honest I don't think that this is a
particularly great structure for black
the rise is almost by force thinking now
after this b5 idea and white here has a
key move from maybe it's an interesting
position for you to look at and ask
yourself what is why it's best move with
this position it's not a tactical move
but more of a strategical move it's not
very difficult but maybe take a couple
of seconds think about the position what
would you play here yeah i'm going to
show you the move nor chrome leaky up
late night to be one a very yeah very
obvious move for four player with a good
strategical understanding the night is
heading to c3 here and this is the ideal
square for the night especially
considering that there is no dark
squared bishop anymore that can
challenge the night in some way this
means the night is just so nice he
planted on c3 always attacking the d5
pawn sometimes intending that's weird
intending 95 in the right circumstances
end it also of course Armand here it
supports efore in the right moment
possibly prepared prepared by f3 and 26
in fact after night be 1 i'm not sure
about I mean the setup that Ramadan
now chooses looks a bit weird to me to
be honest I was I was expecting this
actually that he would put the bishop on
c6 because it's also looking at the at
the e4 square and i'm not i'm not sure
really maybe he was worried about he
form this position this is this my beam
after the capture t5 white is winning
very embarrassing be file but you don't
need to take you can retreat the Queen
and I'm not sure about this position at
all maybe then f3 very complicated
position certainly exactly the type of
position that I'm very sure both players
wanted to have they really played a
super-sharp game here yeah ok went to d6
and now set set up his pieces like that
we should don't really like what is the
bishop doing here isn't it better when
c6 but ok it's it's it's tough to judge
and I don't want to get into into it so
so deeply you see that chronic is
shifting his Queen over to the Kings
side now the King side after all is also
slightly weakened public and you have
some pressure against e5 yeah black
cavity five and I we see some
strengthening moves why doubles on the B
file or this seems very logical night
back to g7 yeah and now maybe there's
not a five coming so white it just
pushes with G form this is not an
attacking move it's a more the
prophylactic move and just simply move
to grep space and control vital squares
key went back to g8 mind queen to f4 we
are going on a dark square king of seven
and now a four
a bit too quick yeah we see that after
some maneuvering White has improved most
of his pieces and it's looking like a
generally nice position for white you
get the beef I'll you know put the be
found this is a bit of a weird piece and
every let's say if you compare the
pieces and the structure everything
points somewhat in whites favor but you
still have an issue in this position how
actually are you going to breach this
this defensive set up and chronic is
playing as you saw it already because I
clicked a bit a bit too much chef
Kramnik played the money for so this is
the kind of yeah and in in German we we
we say using using the crowbar but I'm
not sure if this if this is the right
choice in this position maybe he should
have prepared things a bit a bit more
but ok it's good that he played that
because what we are going to get just in
in a couple of moves is one of the most
hair-raising positions ever saw probably
or at least in recent times okay well II
for has been played and madera responded
with night to e6 yeah um he may be also
was thinking about the capture and this
is I think playable really on d5 is
probably the idea now Queen d6 the only
move yet here White has a choice it can
try for a rook be 7 or play Queen III
which is maybe a bit more complicated
this loopy second is a tactical check
tactical thing now well the
seventh-ranked and the night iya is
attacked so you must play rupee 7
there's no choice yeah and here we come
to a period end game check is very much
forced
and yeah what about this end game hard
to tell I actually believe that after g5
it's probably about equal now might
continue like that Jack yeah and this is
probably going to end in a draw but
can't can continue it because it's not
so relevant for for the whole game but
ok mum Derek I think could have taken
only four it's not not a bad move
probably but 96 is also also interesting
yeah here chronic took on d5 hmm and
this is a really a defining moment for
this game as white will get this poem on
c6 they're actually also was the move
Queen III which wasn't wasn't bad um
Andrew candy to candy to also crazy
stuff one interesting move that the
computer suggests again that leading to
unclear play is night to see five so
good as it looks really strange this is
very good for black so why it will
probably take here and it will continue
like that totally crazy yeah well this
is what chronic plate and it seems to be
okay that's not a bad move at all and it
gets very very sharp now of course it's
a double attack it's a for coming like
that so what must take on f4 and now why
took on c6 yeah and this is already
really crazy position how to how to
assess that white has the strong see
pawn potentially the deep on and on the
other hand this PCM will be will be a
big problem and we see that now but
you're always playing the move
five this is the real problem of of the
position from White's point of view it
would be great with the sea porn and
everything but this g5 movies is a big
problem note that in Mumbai java also
could have played rook takes deform but
this is probably only going to end in a
draw with a wild variation though will
be subject it's very strong I mean white
must do that to save the draw probably
rook b8 and here White has a fantastic
move Knight b5 and this is a mover that
really is doing so many things at once
it's hard to hard to really keep drag it
attacks the rook yeah if the rook go see
for what is obviously even winning if
the route goes somewhere on the D file
let's say here yeah this this is saying
so that's lots of stuff hanging now and
now the best move is rook takes b79
Isaac's Jackie I'm getting something
back here here at what what is a piece
up but the craziest thing is if you
continue this this line c3 we properly
secure a draw yeah but it's a it's a
very very deep line like we'll get this
pawn in addition young he played g5 and
this is also the more principled move
try to just win this Bishop the problem
is if y takes mean this happened on can
put this on the board if white now would
take here there is this subject and yeah
not great what did chrome League do it's
a problem I mean King g6 is also
possibly coming just stabbed picking up
this Bishop yeah Kramnik here played the
movie seven which is the best one
and drama dro replied rook to d6 also
the best move it detects the bishop
immediately and yeah essentially wins
this piece as as shown why term has
nothing better than taking now on g5 and
at least grip porn and pawn for that
check yeah this is exactly happened so
how to assess this position has been
media of just one a piece it's not that
easy if you are if you just count count
stuff White has five pawns you know five
points against three and like as a
piss-up but this is not the whole story
of course the main issue is the spawn on
c7 potentially the deep on and two
somewhat yeah some would loose character
of black's pieces the night on g5 is
unprotected and bishop on a six is also
possible liability but not not a great
one it's simply a case where now
conclude calculation is is king
everything else yes it's just just
nothing you need to just calculate every
possible line as precise as possible
they have five moves to make and both
are on about 10 to 12 minutes yeah
Kramnik now played d 5 which is um a
move that has besides concrete reasons
also some very logical look to it
because it covers e6 so that the night
drawing this weird the night cannot go
to e6 and the effort takes important
space the depart is also a potential
threat in in general and yeah why
prepares further look b8 for example
yeah and up from this position on at
every move you can consider various
alternatives and they're all very very
complicated i believe that Mammadyarov
played played the best movie i played
Bishop rc8 getting the bishop back into
the plate and possibly just taking on g4
it also blocks the sea porn of course I
am this is also very memorable fighting
move they also try to win the game I was
also checking if there are clear drawers
or alternatives look t7 was a move that
I looked at but now I've form now this
is an important point that this night
does not really have any great place to
go if you go to e4 I'm going to take it
rook takes and now a very funny move
yeah Dwight is actually better
threatening c8 and this is a really
weird situation can go here or going to
get get you look back and now have a
much much better rook endgame probably
just winning yeah the position is full
of full of those those tricks yeah
Bishop c8 as mentioned was played by
Mammadyarov and it's a it's a good move
Bishop see aid okay
rupee eight now playback from like this
makes lots of sense yeah the sea porn
needs to be supported by the look and it
seems to be the best moves well yeah now
look FZ look F f6f zex Lex would be six
in German sometimes I have those little
German words creeping in yeah okay rook
f6 and well this this intense look at
form to probably get to the g4 pawn yeah
what the position it's very very tough
now crumbling only with some minutes
left and he now played the moose rucca
aid which at first I thought yeah I'm
not sure it's probably not the most
precise move but who is going to play
with computer like precision in such a
position it seems that a good move here
was not be five I need to show it
anywhere because the lights are so
interesting um yeah the idea is simply
to grab on a seven and then promote and
yeah black can't play night before here
and attending rook f2
takes check takes and now Bishop g4 yeah
and this is this is a draw on this
position it's a a case of yeah enough
counter play against the king and yeah
sometimes let's say here check black and
can even win with an attack like wins
yeah it's a super complicated night b5
was probably the best move there also is
Bishop takes d4 here that black and play
absolutely to do it a bit differently
Bishop takes g4 this can also be played
after might be five um for instance like
that they are just grabbing everything
and yeah well you need to see that white
is got four points for against so if you
manage to just promote you might end up
having an extra pawn in some sort of
endgame but that's not the issue like
your hanger can actually give a ton of
checks IAM and a line like that him is
quite funny check now the move h6 is
quite quite nice keeping the king
trapped on the side of the board and you
can continue this line if white tries to
play something like a five you should
probably play rugby eight you might even
end up in trouble this can easily happen
check
check no c 3 is probably securing the
draw it is a super complicated stuff and
very hard to show in a structured manner
on video because there are so many lines
it at the end it seems that 95 was
probably good for draw um Kramnik played
rukka 8 yeah okay multi drew gave for
this is this is fine white now must play
f3 and here we come to a point no but
it's means 90 move 39 and I'm not sure
about the clock time I think they they
really had less on less time on the
clock I can we cannot believe that in
this kind of position they would simply
have like seven minutes left this makes
no sense at all yeah well okay after f3
here right and protect the g4 and black
no office they can take on f3 and the
question is how how do you take
Mammadyarov took with the rook he also
could have taken with the mind and maybe
this was better on the line that occurs
after that is rook takes CA this is the
critical line rook c8 and now again this
funny move Knight b5 yeah intending
night d 6 and the strange thing is it's
really a position with the rook down but
there's also d6 and night x a 7 this
combined two moose also make life
Twitter for black it seems that this is
a good reply rook g8
just check like that getting to this
position and now 92 is quite strong
black has this very strong cheap on left
and white slide is a bit stranded on CH
this position seems to be quite
substantially better for black on
something like this for example look see
one the rookies attacked just going to
just take take here and yeah here's 9
p-3 salts move but also this probably
not well this is a good one there's this
to get to the deep horn-like is probably
going to win this and it seems that
really night xf3 would have given black
very good winning chances and however
yeah limited time and who is going to
calculate all that he took on f3 with
the rook which is which is not spoiling
the game or anything but Nadia 3 was was
maybe better but very difficult to to to
judge of course after that chronic
played the move d6 he also could have
played but we all move 40 very important
to note this move which looks to be
harnessed a bit insane because well why
does simply allowing a vicious attack by
All Blacks pieces but um this line here
check seems to be an only good enough
for a draw again the White King has some
yeah William it looks like it is on the
ropes but it's nowhere no made apparent
I can can go here this check is even
losing so initiative this check here and
yeah this this seems to be at all why
this just dropping back
um okay if you go here you can lose them
with Brooke edge we made but you can
just go back and always ack just react
to the checks and there's no way I'm
that I'm black and can play for a win
here this is however a difficult move to
play this route be to be a that gives us
all all all defensive ideas and just
yahoo you need to really calculate it to
the end and I'll move 40 not sure that
you want to do that chronic played the
move d 6 which is probably okay as well
and it probably is a you can attach that
to many things that I say yeah because
it's so it's so complicated this
position yeah okay d 6 um in the year
Mammadyarov took on g4 with the bishop
which is I guess the best move he also
if he just wants a draw theoretically
speaking he could have played this one
which is a fairly simple draw you just
give checks here and on this this three
squares a 3g 3h three and white is no
way to prevent that it can take here and
then check get this Halestorm of checks
but okay he wants to win the game why
not black as a piece up and it's it's
completely crazy of course but yeah you
know you won't get a world championship
match if you are you player yeah it's a
chicken type chess airy and every point
i choose the simplest continuation so
this is good Bishop takes you for yeah
and what now what is right supposed to
do now it seems that in this position
can tell you what chronic plate he took
on yet just exchanging rooks and then
play rook I'm to UM to be eight yeah
entering with the second rook it seems
however the
that the best move here was the not to
intuitive move loop to d8 this is
actually given by the computer as the
only move that is playable in this
position which is quite remarkable um
and it's very hard to get to grips what
this move is actually doing it it
prepares g7 yeah there's this much is
clear but it's still not not easy to
evaluate if it should need to draw on
whatever result we can look at lines
here just to try to understand better
what's going on just a reg recheck let's
start with that pot so see so check
gives a check yeah it it still makes
some sense though what is the King going
to do now I guess King edge one mr. is
the best reply and move like king here
check check check leads to a disaster
why discourage egg made it quite nice
what about this move check the same
story leads to the same thing you must
go to h1 and what now okay let's let's
grab the night and see what happens d7
fantastic fantastic position the two
pawns and black is starting an onslaught
with all pieces which is just great yeah
um rookie too it's probably the most
testing continuation you can also try to
play this one but check this at the end
will also be a draw yeah looky to rookie
to this is the the toughest way to play
yeah and now in this position amazingly
enough white only has
one move to save the draw one move and
this is rook g1 if you try rookie fade
for example each looks entirely logical
yeah to get check and go queen with a
check like is ignoring it and just goes
to g7 okay check if you insist and no
not that white cannot simply a promote
or anything I will I should put it can't
what just check mate just once this is
the big threat so jack is check again
check and what now King to h6 yeah and
here in fact black is winning the main
threat is is too strong white can try
this kind of sacrifice but ok I'm not
obliged to take I can just take here and
now win the game there's also Bishop c6
um but ok as mentioned White has a draw
but after rookie to you would have
needed to find rook g1 maybe we had move
but it covers g2 this is the place let's
check occurs so this is the only move to
save it okay rook c2 c2 I really want to
make you and what now don't like a
paycheck yeah and in this position you
really need to take if I go if you go
here I'm going to check check when I
even with white so I need to take check
check and keen to have seven and that's
a no checks and what is white going to
do now are you going to get mated after
all yeah like that check check check I'm
not sure that this is going to enter a
while but this is not necessary White
has a better
a possibility can play Queen to c7
covering the square and if now rook age
two check check check funny up Kingi
three it must be played yeah and of
course i'm close to promoting so Bishop
takes he takes Bishop here okay one and
this is going to be a draw at the end
yeah fantastic line of course this is
super super deep I mean who is going to
calculate that but it needs to be
checked this is what those guys yeah
they needed to calculate all that I came
so Luke t8 what else was there after dat
black I can try 96cm entirely different
approach rook e8 jetta for check also
possibility but however this is
something that will lead to a draw if
dad tries to escape you can you can
check the hack I'm still going to give a
ton of checks and now grab this and this
is no winning attempt for white yeah
something check like that I'm doing here
and i have this protected also rubbed
III possible yeah it seems that this
rook da truth was the way to go in
exactly this position yeah so silly yet
still we had move for some reason okay
prepare c7 but i always try to make
things ought to try to explain those
highly technical moves with some general
consideration why exactly is this good
okay Kramnik didn't do that he played
the capture chan now gave the check
ok and now looked yet so he had the
general idea now poops preparing these
ugly stupid things here preparing d7 but
then it seems to just not completely
it's not not quite working and he if you
look at this first you could have also
played c8 but black has the important
night move to a six to cover d8 will win
the endgame is oresko three pawns okay
we went EMS mentioned yeah and now I'm
it sets check the matter of very very
precise calculation again check here
King age too ok this is what normally I
replayed the check instead of King h2
white also could have gone back here yet
after this check at the end you need to
go to the exact same position as we yes
we have in the game oops sorry check ok
let's let's share this again check need
to go here check this position is is
coming up in the game and it will pop up
in this line as well if I would have
perhaps in this land swap because white
cannot escape here because of the funny
move h6 the King now is is strapped on
the side of the board but let's look at
what happened in the game as mentioned
is the would have bidden this position
would have come up with the other key
move as well took here and now d 7
so we are near the absolute climax here
this game both pawns are close to
promoting check this check and now check
the White King actually needs to go this
route you cannot anymore go here because
of this simple move and this is going to
win for black it's not completely clear
cut though look like look look at this
check check now I mean this still needs
to be one but black we win it he's not
losing any of the pieces which sometimes
can happen of course but he's got this
very important night near the king which
is an excellent defender covering all
those critical squares yeah this is why
chronic went to age form on the side of
the board and yeah this is really crazy
now Mammadyarov Noah took took took some
time and then played we should be six
and this is a very strong move actually
a very very strong move yeah what is
blacks idea it's a it's a very simple
checkmate if white plays a nothing moves
on a let's say let's say he promotes
there just to show it check checkmate
that's the main threat which means you
cannot promote and the thread is so
strong the only move that white has is a
check lukovitch chat check yeah and here
in this position after all this madness
what is no media of doing now he
actually took the rook and this was
really a shocking decision because white
is now queening with the check um and
it's hard to understand why he did that
um especially because while the hotel
is pretty straightforward it's not
considering some other things that
haven't before the really think you
could find if you could have found it
yeah a kingly 6 simply avoiding avoiding
the capture and seems to be very good
and there are two lines now that you
need to calculate look f6 is the first
one this is actually the easy one King
takes check and after this that's funny
there's no check yeah quite amazing
there's no check and black is winning
now within it with us attack here White
has absolutely no defense against the
made threats if you cover the square
like will actually even approach with
the King and get this threat also into
the mix I'm completely winning and and
this is pretty easy I mean so rook ghs
somewhere here must be the thing that he
that he didn't calculate right um king
age 6 cm is the key move after which
this might happen and here there's a
very important point maybe this is
actually what he missed rook cash to
check king g3 and now Bishop takes t7
yeah this maybe this is what he missed
very funny black is still attacking this
wide can take here at the bishop is
stopping the sea porn so something like
that is very very easy when maybe this
is what he had overlooked this is
possible it's not there not so easy
there are various ways to to draw by the
way if black just wants a draw I can
just take the rook there's nothing that
white can do now let's say you promote I
am going back here and now white must
must give a dour and a perpetual so this
made threat so there were various ways
to roll but
he took on a weight really weird I mean
that really if you don't I mean thing is
you you had very simple draws you had a
win and and it takes here which is
really strange and he had lots of time
on the clock okay now white chakra modes
here and now he played relatively
quickly King g7 and it seems that even
here the more firm he came King f7 was
really not not so easy to win against um
for example if after king of seven white
tries to get the new queen check check
we still have the mid going checkmate
okay this is a relatively simple trap I
know but what should white play actually
could play I need to need to hey come on
where is it always promote to Queen
always promote to Queen there it is
check what can actually under promote
here and this is it this is funny move
King f6 it takes Knight takes Queen
takes and now look she said this is for
example I guess a draw could easily
happen and easily happen the thing is
after this king of seven move here King
our seven white seems to have a win
right have to clear win clear means
meaning the result is clear but it's not
like obvious the best move seems to be
king age 5 which seems utterly crazy but
this seems to be the way to go for some
reason
this is g-form king age 6 the king is
actually quite safe now and white will
check promote check again but here in
fact he will check check get the
important a seven-point completely
completely crazy but it seems that he
somehow had planned all this beforehand
and maybe thought that his mating now I
don't know I really don't know the the
the thing is he a chronic played Queen
to be seven and this is just killing
back Knight f3 cheeky i'm going to take
check and that's it maybe he simply had
overlooked queen bee said nah i really
cannot tell i mean because the
alternatives that idea of a look then
they weren't so difficult I mean
comparing to some other things that he
correctly had a says really a bit weird
yeah well Queen B seven that's a killer
this is the threat d8 check yeah like II
cannot give this check on a 3 i'm just
going to take it there is simply no move
here he played this in fact why I took
check and here there is nothing check
can give all those checks but the king
is escaping check here in fact he
resigned I'm not sure if we really
played this on the board it's just here
in the ICC um the ICC moves here yeah
what a game what a game so to just recap
the entire not in every detail but if
you here in this position is not
capturing and playing King g6 white only
a chance check kick h6 group g5 this is
really the last chat possible attempt
and now this ends over like it's just
winning here with an extra piece they
are not even any any tricks can
I mean this is the best that right can
do and black ass an end game with three
extra points so completely completely
over yeah what a tragedy a tragedy at
the end for mamedyarov he really had it
I mean he only only not saying it was
told lazy or anything but just this this
this critical moment had to find the
right continuation and he actually would
have managed to come from being at the
bottom end of the table minus two at the
end losing two games early and then
winning three you would have be really
in contention and with plus one right
behind the the the leaders and now he
lost this game and it's chronic was back
in the race with this with this win
Kramnik now on +1 again it's a he
managed to with this win yeah um make
sure that he managed to get this this
this this point right after he had lost
it Apollo so it's just like as he would
have played two drawers and he's still
okay in terms of overall tournament
standings what a dramatic dramatic end
to this to this fight they both really
fought and did the best and at the enter
from Nick was just the luckier player I
guess it it's yeah it's um quite amazing
how one game can alter the whole curse
curse curr and course of the tournament
yeah curses maybe also involved
somewhere alright I hope you enjoyed the
coverage of this fascinating game to be
honest and I had some some more lines in
my preparation but it's so confusing
that a somewhat to confuse myself at
times so on if you have some time on
your hands
just just to load this game into the
software of your choice or put it on a
on a real board and try to figure out
lines and ideas it's really worth it
tremendously complicated game thanks for
watching